[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing the topic of whether
or not the house of Southern and its
students are inherently evil first off
I'd like to address why would Slytherin
house be evil well throughout the
centuries Southern hasn't always had the
best reputation in fact it started off
with a pretty poor one almost as soon as
it was founded this is of course because
the founding wizard of Southern house
Salazar Slytherin had what we might call
a rather limited view of what it meant
to be a true witch or wizard in fact as
one of the four founding members of
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry Salazar Slytherin indeed
advocated for the school to only admit
pure blood pupils he believed that
muggleborn or Half-Blood witches and
wizards were less than and shouldn't be
permitted access to a magical education
such as the one the founding members
were offering at Hogwarts now while
these views certainly suggest that
silent sauce at the Wren was a rather
Prejudiced and narrow-minded wizard they
don't necessarily mean that he was an
evil man however Salazar Slytherin did
do a great many other things that bring
his character and inherent evilness into
question one of the most obvious
examples being his creation of the
Chamber of Secrets I mean what good
insane person puts a gigantic incredibly
dangerous basilisk with a fatal stair
inside whiz glance that petrifies people
right beneath a school full of children
what good could possibly come out of
that and speaking of snakes there's also
the fact that Salazar was a parcel
tongue meaning that he had the ability
to speak to snakes and serpent-like
creatures this alone certainly doesn't
make him evil but if you add the fact
that almost every parcel tongue that
we're aware of was pretty evil like
Voldemort in the gaunt family it
definitely doesn't do Salazar so they're
in any favors in supporting his
character another incredibly obvious
reason to question the inherent
qualities of Southern in its students is
the sheer number of evil witches and
wizards who were once sorted into that
house in fact rubius Hagrid even said to
a young impressionable Harry in the
Philosopher's Stone is not a single
witch or wizard who went bad who wasn't
in Slytherin you know who was one and as
we discover throughout the remainder of
the series Voldemort was in good company
with many once suthering students going
to do a great number of terrible things
while there are obviously too many to
recount in today's video a few of the
more famous and well-known examples
include the likes of Bellatrix Lestrange
Dolores Umbridge the house of Malfoy
including Lucius and Draco the houses of
black and gaunt the student torturing
Cairo Twins and just about every single
Death Eater we are ever introduced to so
while Hagrid wasn't necessarily lying in
saying that evil witches and wizards
came out of Southern he also wasn't
entirely correct either for there have
also been a number of other incredibly
evil wizards who have come from other
Hogwarts houses as well to start with
with there was Peter Pettigrew
Gryffindor student former best friend of
James Potter Sirius Black and rumors
Lupine and murderous traitor as you may
recall Peter more often referred to as
wormtail who committed the ultimate Act
of betrayal against his supposed closest
friends breaking the effect of the
fidelius charm after being chosen by The
Potters as their Secret Keeper wormtel
did this by sharing the location of
James Lilly and little baby Harry with
Voldemort who wanted to hunt the family
down and kill them and as Despicable as
that was Peter didn't stop there no
indeed wormtail went on to betray yet
another best friend almost immediately
after that framing Sirius Black for the
Betrayal of The Potters as well as
Peter's own murder a death Witch of
course Peter faked as a result of
wormtale's actions James and Lily were
killed Harry became an orphan and Sirius
was falsely imprisoned in Azkaban for a
decade yet another example of an evil
wizard from a Hogwarts house other than
Slytherin is Professor Aquarius quarrel
who was actually a former Ravenclaw
student while it's arguable that much of
curl's evil actions were a result of
Voldemort having possessed him it was
indeed his hubris and intention of
learning the dark arts to become a great
and powerful wizard that got him into
that situation in the first place he
wanted to learn what had become a
Voldemort and returned from his tour
around the world with knowledge powerful
enough to make a name for himself that's
even the room at the party Crouch Jr the
wizard who captured an impersonated Mad
Eye Moody and killed his own father was
a student of either Ravenclaw or
Hufflepuff not Slytherin in addition to
the fact that not all evil witches and
wizards were once other in students
there's also a substantial number of
pupils who were sutherings and who
turned out to be good even great people
the most obvious example of this is the
famed wizard Merlin as one of the first
students to go through Hogwarts taught
by Salazar Slytherin himself Merlin
exemplified all the positive attributes
that are associated with Southern
it was ambitious resourceful determined
and clever and his mark on The Wizarding
World was so great the wizard gamut an
ancient governing body that predates the
ministry of magic has given out annual
Awards known as the order of Merlin of
the first second and third class since
the 15th century in fact the first class
order of Merlin is a gold medal which
hangs on a green ribbon said to be a
reflection of his house at Hogwarts
Merlin was also an advocate of Mughal
rights proving that not all Southerns
were obsessed with blood Purity and
elitism then of course there is
Professor Severus Snape who at times
seemed to have mixed loyalties but who
inevitably showed his inherent goodness
a trait which seems clearly motivated by
his love for Lilly poser do other former
slytherins who were also similarly
motivated by love were Andromeda Tonks
and Lita Lestrange
both of these women took positive and
even heroic action in the Name of Love
Andromeda cut ties with her blood Purity
obsessed family the house of black and
married muggleborn TED talks and Lita
Lestrange sacrificed herself to save
Brothers Theseus and Newt scamander in
the face of the dark wizard Gaelic
Grindelwald at the time Lita was engaged
to be married to Theseus and had a
long-standing affection for her
childhood friend nudes there's also
Slytherin alumni Professor Horace
Slughorn who yes and a weird elitist
club with students who he believed would
give him a sort of credibility but he
was certainly not an evil wizard and
last we forget regulus black who went
against his family's beliefs and stole
Voldemort's four cracks understanding
that its terrible and Powerful nature
must be stopped so as you can see the
traits of Southern students while often
associated with self-absorbed haughty
and yes evil witches and wizards do not
always translate that way in fact the
quality of a Slytherin student ambition
resourcefulness determination and
cleverness don't seem all that bad or
evil in nature to me at all and is it
just me or do those traits kind of sound
like a combination of Gryffindor and
Ravenclaw two houses that absolutely no
one Associates with inherent evilness
and yet many Gryffindor students are
actually quite Reckless and loud in
their attempts to be brave or courageous
this probably accounts for some of the
last and okay actions of James Potter
and his fellow Marauders as you may
recall the group bullied a feeble and
substantially less popular Severus Snape
on many occasions during their time as
students together at Hogwarts in fact
the Gryffindor boys even magically
lifted Severus in the air and dangled
him upside down by his feet while
taunting him with Petty name-calling a
pretty terrible thing to do to another
pupil and one that you may have been
quick to associate with Southern not
Gryffindor one could also argue that
some of the Ravenclaw values could lead
a witch or wizard down path take the
ghost of the gray lady for example her
real name being Helena Ravenclaw the
daughter of Hogwarts founding member
Rowena Ravenclaw so obsessed with
stepping out of her mother's enormous
Shadow and becoming more well known for
her intelligence than Rowena she stole
her mother's magic diadem and ran away
sharing with Harry in the Deathly
Hallows I stole the diadem I sought to
make myself cleverer more important than
my mother I ran away with it tragically
this act of betrayal and vanity
inevitably cost Helena her life which
again seems more a tale of a Slytherin
rather than a Ravenclaw and yet it's not
finally I'd like to provide you with an
example or two a few hufflepuffs who oh
wait never mind no Hufflepuff with their
strong sense of justice loyalty patience
and a propensity for hard work has ever
been evil and with that we've come to
the end of another video what did you
think do you believe that the House of
Slytherin is evil please share your
thoughts in the comments below and as
always if you enjoyed this video Don't
forget to like it and subscribe to the
channel until next time remember it does
not do to dwell on dreams and forget to
live